I learned and I think he learned as well
you know one of the funny jokes somebody
told me was they said in Washington if
you want to keep a secret between three
people two of them have to be dead right
and so you know but it wasn't quite that
bad I think it was a function of in the
beginning I felt very very helpless
right like I said I think something and
like it would link to the Washington
Post it was so bad yeah and I think with
him too so so a couple of things I again
I read about how I adjusted and said
okay the game is the game it's been here
long before me it's gonna be here long
after me you know you have a chance to
be in the game if you are in the game
you can get good things done but you
have to get better at the game
so then the campaign's starting and I've
talked to Don Jr about this publicly on
this show and privately like he was
telling me how so many people that were
lifelong friends has suddenly deserted
him and just all of that nonsense so now
you and Ivanka are intimately involved
in this thing and then he wins now
you're going to DC I mean first off did
you have just a whole bunch of friends
that shed you immediately and how insane
was just getting to DC and then seeing
what that was like so believe it or not
we didn't and I think that what what
happened was is I think through my
father's experience I was very selective
in who I let in so Ivanka and I have a
very uh close relationship and a lot of
our time in New York we spent just the
two of us right if we had to choose to
go into a dinner party or being with us
we would be with us and we would always
love doing different Adventures going on
dates you know trying new restaurants
seeing new neighborhoods and then as we
started building a family that was a
priority for us as well and we'd had a
ton of acquaintances you know from New
York but uh but the people who are our
real friends were people who we thought
were very quality people who we got
things out of and and I think who got
things out of us and those people were
all people mostly on the left of the
political Spectrum again I had probably
one conservative friend that I could
think of from before this experience but
everyone was very respectful and very
very open of what we were doing and
recognized that again it wasn't Ivanka
and I who were you know giving speeches
or making policies it was her father and
you know she was doing what uh what a
devoted daughter would do
um but for me I was much more
open-minded and much much more
uh studying the policies I think for
Ivanka she basically said okay if this
is the situation that's happening she
had a mission-driven business at the
time where there were issues she was
advocating for she said well if I can
use this as a platform to elevate the
issues like she cared about like paid
family leave and
um and and child care
um she says well then I think it's kind
of irresponsible not to do that so she
gave a speech at the RNC introducing her
father and all the things on the
internet after was saying was did she
think she was at the Democratic
Convention because they were not
traditionally right Republican policies
um and that her dad used to be loved by
the Democrats I mean there's no shortage
of pictures of with all those people
when they used to love him and he was
donating to some of them yeah being in
New York and again he was part of Pop
Culture yeah so yeah but but the short
answer is is that you know our friends
were were really strong and and really
still are and uh what I found is that
um when we decided to go to Washington
and I write about kind of how we made
that decision because it wasn't like we
were thinking okay he's going to win and
then this is going to happen right the
whole campaign was like let's get to
goal line plus an inch like you know who
the hell knows how this is going to work
out but you do talk about that you kind
of thought it was going to happen the
whole time right I didn't again
logically it felt like he should be able
to do it right all the math and I I can
go to a whole thing on polling but
from what I saw was like the polling all
seemed like it was not scientific right
so if you look at all the public polling
that predicted he was going to lose I
was shocked by how many people just
followed it but polling is basically you
call 500 people and they say yes or no
and then you have to do something called
uh awaiting right and waiting is
basically you say okay this is what okay
if we called you know 100 Democrats and
100 Republicans how many people who
think are going to vote and then you
kind of recalculate the the results in
order to do that so what happened in
brexit right before Trump won was
the polling was off massively now it
predicted the amount of people who said
stay pretty accurately but it was off by
about 3 million votes for the people who
predicted to leave and as we I
researched why that was I was reading
all the the info on it it basically said
that they just under counted low
propensity voters and so with Trump uh
all the media was using basically the
Obama Romney turnout model and I was
like I don't think that's indicative
right like Obama had a different
electricity that Hillary didn't have and
and Trump had a different electricity
that Romney didn't have so it felt like
it should be different and then when I
look at we had a data we built a data
file about 10 million people were
showing up to Trump rallies and a big
percentage of them were low propensity
voters and so we basically every time we
do a sample which we we re-engineered
the polling we basically ran it through
two different models one was like the
media model which showed we were going
to lose and what was our model showed we
were going to win and so I just again
you know Romney went into election night
thinking they were going to win if I was
told and then were disappointed so I
never allowed myself to believe our data
because I'd never done it before and so
but that was what I believed was more
logical as an outcome but we didn't
think about what would come next
sorry it's such a long no no So speaking
of what came next so now you get there
and I now you're working for the
president and media is not that happy
CNN New York Times okay all that stuff
but you guys actually were accomplishing
an awful lot pretty much from the gecko
considering you had no nobody willing to
to work with you yeah so it was a wild
thing and and the first year in writing
the book I went through the first year
and it brought back a lot of memories
that actually were really painful for me
because hey we get to Washington so we
make the decision to to and it wasn't
like oh should we stay in New York and
live our lives or should we go to
Washington was like okay he is now going
to be the president United States our
former lives as we knew it don't exist
anymore right so and then you say you
have an opportunity to serve in in
government and try to make an impact and
I build more confidence based on the
fact that on campaign I was able to
achieve certain successes and things
um that experienced political people
told me was the wrong way to do it but
then I did it that way and it ended up
working
and so I said let's give it a shot and
let's try to help him and again you know
he'd never been a mayor never been a
governor so he was running a family
business he was used to working with
family his campaign was a family
campaign and so we said let's go give it
a shot and and really try to see if we
could help him implement the policies
that we believe in and try to do things
that we believe are good so Ivanka gave
up her business to then focus on her
Mission I went in
and we had no idea what a brutal world
uh Washington was going to be and so
whether it was like the attacks from the
media whether it was the investigation I
mean within three months I have you know
people leaking on me like crazy from
inside the White House you know you talk
to yourself and it would be in the
Washington Post uh wait can you just
talk about a little bit more about what
that's like the leak situation like how
is it possible because everyone's always
talking about the leaks they were
talking about an awful lot with Trump
but it happens in every Administration
like
did you feel like oh here's 10 people in
this room in this meeting like six of
them might be the one or like how do you
manage some of that stuff as an advisor
or do you pull him aside and say hey Mr
President maybe don't or dad-in-law or
whatever you call him Don do you maybe
don't say everything you think off the
cuff in front of everybody because we
have this problem like so so I think I
learned and I think he learned as well
you know one of the funny jokes somebody
told me was they said in Washington if
you want to keep a secret between three
people two of them have to be dead right
and so you know but it wasn't quite that
bad I think it was a function of in the
beginning I felt very very helpless
right like I said I think something and
like it would link to the Washington
Post it was so bad yeah and I think with
him too so so a couple of things I again
I write about how I adjusted and said
okay the game is the game it's been here
long before me it's gonna be here long
after me you know you have a chance to
be in the game if you are in the game
you can get good things done but you
have to get better at the game and so
certain things like when I would give my
opinion to Donald especially when I
would disagree with him I would always
do it when I I would never say my
opinion in front of other people or I
would say something that I didn't think
would be salacious but when I wanted to
strongly disagree I would always do it
privately because you never wanted to
read about that in the Press because
that would if you I never wanted
division to to show between us because
he always gave me the opportunity to
voice my opinion and sometimes he would
listen sometimes he wouldn't again I was
an advisor and some things quite frankly
I had more conviction on some things I
had less conviction on and often when he
would ask me I'd say look I'm not an
expert on it let me find somebody who I
think is and bring them in to give you
that point of view um but but so that
was probably number one and then when it
came to just dealing with people you
learned very quickly like who was
leaking to which places and right we
just had so many of them who were
scumbags who were doing that were they
all your guys
you know what I mean or were they were
they like sort of deep State people that
were all there all the time or were they
were there a lot of them were the people
coming in look we we I mean we didn't
have a lot of people right and and you
know the campaign was ragtag uh we had
to staff up quickly or making a lot of
decisions putting different people
together and uh yeah you just have
people and then you know the more people
get insecure the more they it's an
environment that that kind of encourages
more of it so it's it's a very very
complicated situation to work in but
like I said I figured out how to adjust
I got tighter
um and then ultimately over time like
towards the end we we announced a peace
deal which which we'll talk about later
but like and nobody knows about it right
so so I learned how to find the people
who you could work with to keep things
quiet but it just took me some time and
like when you work in you know real
estate or technology like nobody's out
there leaking to the Press right and
everyone's aligned for the same Mission
too so it's just a different game and
you just have to learn to adjust to the
game if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our pilot politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell